hi this is presto Walker and today I
want to discuss a very interesting
problem which is an example of how game
theory solved a religious mystery this
is going to be a little involved so I'm
going to cut right to the chase and get
to the problem this appears as a
bankruptcy problem in the religious
document the Talmud and the set up is
that a man owes debts of 100 200 and 300
but he does not have enough money to pay
everyone off how should his estate be
divided among these three creditors
before we get to the Prancer and how
game theory solved it I just want to
take a moment to say there really is no
right answer there's no one way that you
can say the estate should be divided
there are many different ways you can
divide it it depends on social customs
and norms you know when people go to
restaurants that's an example where
people order different things and
eventually the bill comes some people
just decide to split the bill evenly
other people decide to split it based on
what they order you can even have more
you know intricate things like we'll
split the wine evenly but you know you
pay for everything else on your own so
there's no right answer what will be
interesting is to see that you know
whenever you have a method you're
interested that it's consistently
applied to everyone and you want also
are curious of what the rationale is you
know I just gave you some examples in a
restaurant that some people are fine
with proportional division which is
paying for what you order other people
you know they just like to split the
bill evenly they say you know they're
ten people here divide the bill by ten
so how does the Talmud do this well the
Talmud setup is actually based on the
fact that this man is three wives who
whom he owes 100 200 and 300 and the
the division given in the text was very
curious and people didn't didn't
understand it so we're going to talk
about how the talmud did it the division
in the text seems to depend on the size
of the SD so it depends there's not a
single method on how to divide up the
money but there's a method that depends
on how big the estate is so one example
in the text is if the man died with a
hundred the solution is that each person
should get even split which is thirty
three and a third
interestingly this is not what happens
if if the man dies with 300 in this case
there's a proportional split of 50 100
and 150 you could understand this as
something we might use in modern legal
settings that you know if a company goes
bankrupt you have to divide up the
assets and you would give it to the
creditor is based on how much each of
them claim so the person who claims 300
obviously you know she gave up three
times as much as the person who has a
100 day this one makes sense but it's
also already we're kind of seeing why
you know why should the division be
different between 100 and 300 why should
one be an even split and why should one
be a proportional split even this
solution itself might be okay but things
get really weird when the sdata is 200
in this case the text indicates that the
split should be 50 75 and 75 this really
is very curious it's I can't you know
off the top of my head think of any
justification for it in any common
setting that we ever have this is
clearly not an even split of the money
it's not 200 divided three ways it's
also not a proportional split where the
person who has more you know up
a debt claim gets more money you have
this weird thing where the person who
has a debt of 100 gets 50 of that and
the other two people they just get 75 so
how you know this is this is what was
the religious mystery it's how you know
why would the Tollman have these
divisions and it actually was so
puzzling that some people say that it's
you know some academics actually said
this was just a transcription error
there's no way that these three cases
could have been compatible there just
doesn't seem to be any logic to it now
before we get to the explanation it'll
be useful to summarize these numbers in
a table so I'm going to have a three by
three table the columns will be
representing the three different people
who have claims on the debt of one
hundred two hundred three hundred and we
will will write out the Talmud division
as follows if you know there's one case
where the S state is a hundred and each
person is supposed to get thirty three
and a third so we're going to fill out
the three columns we're going to fill
out the row as each person getting
thirty three and a third we can do a
similar exercise
you know let's go to the next case where
the S state is three hundred in this
case the split is 50 100 and 150 will
again fill out these rows corresponding
to the people of claims 100 200 and 300
and finally we get to the the weird case
a you know when the S state size is 200
and now we fill in these cells again as
50 75 and 75 so this is a way we can
summarize for any you know given s state
size how much money should be given to
the three different people who have
different claims on debts so this this
is it's just it's just a very weird
table if you think about it the first
row is an even split the last rows of
proportional split and the middle row
just doesn't
to have any sense it doesn't reconcile
with these methods at all so how to
explain these numbers well in the 1980s
professors Robert Ullman who's now lone
belt laureate and Michael Maslow wrote a
paper claiming a game through
explanation on on the logic behind these
numbers I provided the sources in the
description of the video you should
definitely check out the original paper
it's a very interesting read very nice
explanation that's what I'm basing this
entire problem in the presentation so
let's try and see what they did how they
could have come up with this so we're
going to go just this is to explain sort
of the game theory principle or just a
social custom of how you divide things
there's something they termed an equal
division of a contested some so that
means if two people are arguing about a
certain amount whatever they're arguing
about whatever is contested you should
split that between them so that's the
principle that we're going to to use to
try to understand the division so let's
let's get to an example of this how this
would work so the the justification for
this is this is another example in the
Talmud so there's one person who claims
that an entire garment is his and
another person who claims ownership on
half of it what is the correct way and
what's one possible way to divide this
according to the equal division of
contested some so what we have here is
we have half of the garment is basically
in dispute we could say that's the sum
that's contested so what we want to do
with equal division is we divide that
half between the two people so the
person who wants a who claims to own a
half will get 1/4 the other person will
also get 1/4 and then there's the
remaining half which only one person
claims so we add that all they're half
in so what ends up happening is we have
a division
that's 1/4 and 3/4 the 1/4 is the equal
division of the contested sum and the
remaining half is uncontested and given
to the person claiming the entire
garment we can summarize this division
kind of using the same tables we've been
you know using the fourth so we can have
the S state size which is just the one
garment and that's a one whole piece of
garment and there are claims of 1/2 and
1 so the person who claims one-half gets
1/4 and the person who claims 1 it gets
3/4 so let's summarize this algorithm
what we need to do it's three steps we
first determine what portion is
contested then we divide that evenly and
finally anything that's uncontested is
given to the person who claims it that's
simple
so we add up those numbers and we have a
division according to equal division of
the contestant song let's go through
this a couple examples of this let's
imagine two creditors have claims of 100
and 300 and there's an S state that's
not not sufficient enough it's 66 and
2/3 so how are we going to divide this
according to the equal division of the
contested sum well clearly as you can
see both of them claim you know more
than the S state so the entire estate is
in dispute and that means each of them
should be getting half of it so that's
33 and 1/3 going to each party let's
imagine you know we can make it a little
more interesting we increase the estate
size so now it's 125 and that that's
bigger than the claim of 100 so now it's
not the entire estate of 125 that's in
dispute that first hundred of the S
state is being claimed by both parties
and that remaining 25 is only being
claimed by the person claiming 300 so if
we use the same three steps
we divide up the 50 sorry we divide up
the hundred evenly as 50 going to each
party and then we let the remaining 25
go to the 300 claiming so this results
in a division of 50 and 75 we'll just do
one more example let's imagine the S
state is 200 now we have similarly still
the first hundred is contested by both
the next hundred is only claimed by the
300 person so we go through the
algorithm and we end up with the
division of 50 and 150 we can summarize
all these claims in the same sort of
table where we have claims of 100 300 we
have different s state sizes and we end
up with the division of how they should
be given let's do more examples of this
this is too much fun we can imagine
different claim sizes you know these are
going to be two examples claims of 100
200 different s state sizes we can also
do claims of 200 300 with different
estate sizes I'm just going to keep
going through ahead I don't want to go
through every example we end up with
these different tables and you can check
and verify that these make sense but now
now comes the interesting part do any of
these numbers and any of these tables
look familiar and the answer is yes it's
if you merge all these tables together
you get the 3 by 3 table that's in the
Talmud and that's where the mystery is
solved is that basically the Talmud
answer is an equal division of contested
sum for each pair of creditors so here
are the different tables we came up with
here's the big table from the Talmud and
just an example we can see where the
numbers from the 100 claimant come from
you can do the same thing for the 200
and the 300 claimant and that's kind of
why it's weird you know it's but that
explains where all these numbers come
from
I think the mystery is solved
please subscribe to my channel I do
videos on math and game theory you can
also check me out on my blog mind your
decisions right do weekly puzzles on
Monday weekly Game three posts on
Tuesday and at Twitter at pressure
soccer
thank you